.
Freunde der Sonne.
FreundInnen der Sonne?
Das Video hier ist etwas anders.
Gebt ihm trotzdem eine Chance.
Seit einiger Zeit
beschäftigt mich eine Frage.
Ich hoffe, diese Frage
nach dem Video und euren Kommentaren
ein bisschen besser für
mich selbst beantworten zu können.
Die Frage lautet:
sollte man gendern?
- Sollte man was?
Sollte ich, wenn ich
über Wissenschaftler rede,
lieber über Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler reden
oder über WissenschaftlerInnen?
Bevor ihr jetzt denkt, was für 'ne
Social-Justice-Warrior-Kacke...
äh-äh-äh-äh. Pscht!
Keine Sorge,
es wird eine rationale Abhandlung.
Ich möchte folgendes machen:
ich möchte zuerst erklären,
warum diese Frage wichtig ist.
Dann möchte ich Argumente
für und gegen Gendern aufführen.
Wozu mich auch
eure Meinung interessiert.
Am Ende habe ich eine Art
Announcement, einen Aufruf an euch.
Keinen Aufruf, einen Kommentar zu
schreiben oder das Video zu liken.
Könnt ihr auch machen!
Aber mehr als das. Wir suchen euch!
Eins nach dem anderen.
Holt euch 'nen Tee, setzt euch.
Warum mache ich mir
Gedanken übers Gendern?
Ich fand in der Schule Mathe gut,
Naturwissenschaften gut,
hab mich für ein Chemiestudium
entschieden. Danach promoviert.
Bei alldem hat mein Geschlecht
in meinem Kopf keine Rolle gespielt.
Wann immer ich das Wort Chemiker
gehört hab, dachte ich nie,
Chemiker, sondern Chemiker.
Ich sage sogar manchmal,
ich bin Chemiker.
Anstatt: ich bin Chemikerin.
Ohne groß darüber nachzudenken.
Habe mir auch nie Gedanken gemacht,
wie schaffe ich ein Chemiestudium
oder ein Physikstudium
oder ein Maschinenbaustudium.
Als Mädchen. Oder Frau.
Zum Glück habe ich mir
nie diese Gedanken gemacht.
Sonst wäre ich wahrscheinlich
nicht Chemikerin geworden.
Weil ich damals auch noch nicht so
selbstgewusst war, wie heute.
Wie es so ist, wenn man jünger ist.
Bis zum Ende meiner Doktorarbeit
hätte ich niemals daran gedacht,
bei einem Vortrag zu gendern.
Wenn ich von Chemikern
oder Wissenschaftlern
oder Kollegen gesprochen habe.
Wenn mich jemand gebeten hätte, auch
mal Chemikerinnen usw. anzusprechen,
hätte ich gesagt: warum?
Weiß doch jeder, was gemeint ist.
Hätte mir jemand gesagt, dass
ich ein ganzes Video dazu mache,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich gesagt,
nein, sorry, habe andere Probleme.
* Schlürf * Meine persönliche
Wahrnehmung hat sich nicht geändert.
Aber mein Beruf hat sich geändert.
Bin nicht mehr Wissenschaftlerin,
sondern Wissenschaftsjournalistin.
Und Wissenschafts-Kommunikatorin.
Früher waren Heizplatte
und Spatel meine Werkzeuge.
Heute ist es Sprache.
Und Sprache ist für viele
Naturwissenschaftler: bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla. Bla bla bla.
Für Naturwissenschaftler
ist die einzig sinnvolle Sprache
Fachsprache.
Die sachlich
und klar definiert ist.
Deswegen fällt es gerade
Naturwissenschaftlern oft schwer,
andere Menschen zu erreichen.
Und zu bewegen.
Normale Sprache hat
im Gegensatz zu Fachsprache
viel mehr Ebenen
und Bedeutungen.
Dadurch ist Sprache genial
und tückisch zugleich.
Denn sie beeinflusst
unsere Wahrnehmung ganz stark.
Wer's nicht glaubt, schaue sich
unser Video zu Farben an.
Deswegen sehe ich
sämtliche sprachlichen Fragen,
auch die Frage nach dem Gendern,
ziemlich technisch.
Denn wie kann ich meine Sprache
möglichst gut einsetzen,
um das zu erreichen, was ich möchte?
Ich möchte Wissenschaft vermitteln
an möglichst viele Menschen.
Das ist mein Beruf,
meine Leidenschaft.
Deswegen ist Sprache
mit all ihren kleinen Nuancen,
die für manche vielleicht
ein bisschen pille-palle klingen,
für mich sehr wichtig geworden.
Was spricht jetzt fürs Gendern,
was dagegen?
Ich mache jetzt einen Schlagabtausch
mit mir selbst.
Pro Mai: "Man sollte gendern!"
Gegen Contra Mai: "Nein!"
Ihr seid die Jury. Los geht's.
Pro-Argument Nummer 1:
Gendern ist gute Kommunikation.
Lange Zeit hatte ich relativ
wenig ZuschauerInnen.
Je mehr Freunde der Sonne und
Freundinnen der Sonne hinzukamen,
desto öfter begegnete ich Menschen,
in den Kommentaren, in Nachrichten,
oder im real life
die mir sagten, sie fänden es schön,
würde ich gendern.
Und die mir das auch respektvoll
und verständnisvoll erklärten.
Ich treffe Mädchen und junge Frauen,
die mir sagen,
sie fühlen sich ernsthaft
nicht angesprochen,
wenn ich von
Chemikern und Wissenschaftlern rede.
Mein Credo ist, Kommunikation ist
nicht das, was du sagst oder meinst,
sondern nur das,
was beim anderen ankommt.
Wer nicht dazu bereit ist, sich in
sein Publikum hinein zu versetzen,
der kann kein guter Kommunikator,
keine gute Kommunikatorin sein.
Würde ich die Sorgen meiner
ZuschauererInnen nicht ernst nehmen,
und mit jedem "Wissenschaftler",
"Chemiker" und "Physiker"
Mädchen und Frauen ausschließe,
die dadurch subtil
den Eindruck bekommen,
Wissenschaftler
seien meistens Männer,
dann wäre das sehr, sehr schade.
Gegen-Argument 1: Gendern ist
schlechte Kommunikation.
Der sehr gute Wissenschafts-
Kommunikator Jean Luc Dumont sagt:
Kommunikation ist nie neutral,
sie ist immer 1 von 2 Sachen,
entweder signal oder noise.
Also Signal oder Rauschen.
Alles, was du eigentlich vermitteln
willst, ist Signal.
Alles, was kein Signal ist,
ist Rauschen, Störung, Ablenkung.
Ein guter Text hat keine Füllwörter,
die keinen Zweck erfüllen.
Diese Füllwörter sind Rauschen.
Sie verschlechtern
die "signal to noise ratio",
wie Wissenschaftler gerne sagen.
Wenn ich über Impfen rede,
ist das Geschlecht
der Wissenschaftler irrelevant.
Demnach ist es kein Signal,
sondern Rauschen.
Diese Info lenkt ab.
Vor allem, wenn es in den Ohren
vieler holprig klingt.
Und dann fanden die
WissenschaftlerInnen Folgendes raus:
- Oh, hier. - Hä? - Ich dachte,
du hast dich verschluckt.
Wenn ich stattdessen sage:
Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler.
Oder noch besser:
Naturwissenschaftlerinnen
und Naturwissenschaftler.
Dann wird das sehr lang
und nimmt dadurch automatisch
in meinem Satz Gewicht ein,
obwohl es inhaltlich
keine große Rolle spielen sollte.
Wobei man einräumen muss,
dass es vor allem ablenkt,
weil wir es nicht gewohnt sind,
"WissenschaftlerInnen" zu hören.
Wenn es aber jeder so sagen würde,
wenn wir es nicht anders
kennen würden,
hätten wir
dieses Kommunikationsproblem nicht.
Pro-Grund 2:
Sprachliches Repräsentieren.
Man könnte jetzt sagen:
Wie unwichtig sind
so kleine Endungen wie "-innen",
wenn wir doch über wichtige Dinge
wie Wissenschaft sprechen.
Einerseits stimmt das natürlich,
andererseits sind kleine,
oberflächliche Dinge,
nun einmal wichtig.
Ob wir es wollen oder nicht.
Es sollte keine Rolle spielen, wer
hier gerade vor der Kamera sitzt.
Auf diesem Kanal geht es um Inhalte.
Trotzdem spielt es natürlich
eine Rolle, wie ich aussehe.
Und ob ihr mich sympathisch findet?
Ob ihr euch mit mir
identifizieren könnt?
Es sollte keine Rolle spielen,
wenn wir über Wissenschaft reden.
Aber zu glauben, dass es
in der Realität, in der Praxis,
tatsächlich keine Rolle spielt,
dies zu glauben wäre naiv.
Auch wenn unsere Community
da wahrscheinlich offener ist,
ist der ganze MINT-Bereich,
MINT steht für Mathe, Informatik,
Wissenschaft, Technik,
der ist in unserer Gesellschaft
immer noch stereotypisch männlich.
Ich persönlich kenne privat
viele Naturwissenschaftlerinnen
und Ingenieurinnen
und Informatikerinnen.
Fast alle meine engen Freundinnen
sind MINT-lerinnen.
Aber ich sehe sie nicht in
den Medien. Oder hier auf YouTube.
Also in YouTube-Deutschland
bin ich als weibliches Gesicht
für einen MINT-Kanal
ziemlich alleine.
Schaut doch mal die YouTube-Trends.
Die Geschlechter-Stereotypen
sind da extrem stark.
Mädels machen Beauty,
und Jungs machen Gaming.
Sollte sich das nicht ändern?
Ich will nichts erzwingen,
was völlig unnatürlich ist.
Ich finde es nur krass,
wie sich meine Realität
mit all den coolen
Wissenschaftlerinnen, die ich kenne,
komplett unterscheidet
von dieser seltsamen Welt,
die wir auf YouTube sehen.
Als erwachsene Frau mit inzwischen
ausreichendem Selbstbewusstsein
kann ich das ganze auch aus der
Distanz analysieren und einordnen.
Mir schauen ja auch
viele junge Zuschauerinnen zu.
Die sich durch diese
Geschlechter-Stereotypen
stark beeinflussen lassen.
So gesehen fände ich es schön,
Chemikerinnen, Ingenieurinnen,
Informatikerinen wenigstens
sprachlich sichtbar zu machen.
Wenn Sie sonst schon
so unsichtbar sind.
Gegen-Argument 2: nichts
sprachliches repräsentieren.
MINT sollte nichts
mit dem Geschlecht zu tun haben.
Warum betonen wir sprachlich
das Mannsein oder Frausein?
Wenn es doch keine Rolle
spielen sollte?
Möchte ich jetzt wirklich sagen: Du
bist ein Mädchen, du kannst Mathe.
Sollte es nicht einfach scheißegal
sein, ob du ein Mädchen bist
oder nicht?
Am besten wäre meiner Meinung nach
ein geschlechtsneutraler Ausdruck.
Den haben wir schon.
Es ist in der deutschen Sprache
der männliche Plural.
Sollten wir nicht lieber versuchen,
einen männlich assoziierten Plural
wie "Wissenschaftler" in unseren
Köpfen geschlechtsneutral zu machen?
Das englische Wort "Scientist"
ist wirklich geschlechtsneutral.
Trotzdem denken
die meisten Englischsprachigen
wahrscheinlich an einen Mann, wenn
sie das Wort "Scientist" hören.
Wie können wir
die Wahrnehmung eines Wortes
in den Köpfen verändern?
Es ist nicht leicht. Aber ich sitze
jetzt hier vor dieser Kamera.
Wenn ich sage, ich bin Chemiker.
Mache ich dadurch nicht glasklar,
dass Chemiker
nicht auch Frauen sind?
So viel zum Schlagabtausch.
Was denkt ihr?
- Aber Mai,
was denkst du denn jetzt?
- Wer aufmerksam Videos geschaut
hat, ist vielleicht aufgefallen,
ich habe mich etwas ausprobiert.
Ich habe mal versucht, zu gendern,
indem ich sowas wie
WissenschaftlerInnen sage.
Meistens versuche ich,
beim Plural weibliche und männliche
Formen einfach abzuwechseln.
Manchmal gender ich auch
überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe noch keine elegante Lösung,
mit der ich 100 % zufrieden bin.
Kommen wir zu euch und dem Aufruf:
Mich nervt am meisten, dass ich
im Jahr 2018 mir über sowas hier
immer noch Gedanken machen muss.
Dass ich mir überhaupt Gedanken
machen muss,
wie ich
weibliche Zuschauer erreiche,
weil das doch eigentlich scheißegal
sein sollte. Hauptsache Science!
Nur bei einer Sache
bin ich mir sicher:
Mehr weibliche Medien-Repräsentation
in typisch männlichen Bereichen
wie MINT. Oder Gaming usw.
Kann auf jeden Fall nicht schaden.
Das würde ich mir wünschen.
Dasselbe gilt für Männer
in typisch weiblichen Bereichen.
Aber eine Baustelle
nach der anderen.
Wenn ihr auch findet,
dass Medien-Repräsentation
ein erster Schritt
in die richtige Richtung ist.
Wenn ihr nicht nur Kommentare
schreiben wollt,
sondern aktiv werden wollt,
meldet euch bei uns: bei FUNK.
Das geht natürlich an alle. Aber
besonders an meine Ladys da draußen,
denn FUNK sucht dich.
Wenn du Mathe wunderschön findest
oder Programmieren
spannender als Mode.
Nix gegen Mode.
Oder wenn du in deiner Freizeit
gerne Raketen baust. Wie auch immer.
Wir suchen MINT-Menschen.
Mathe, Informatik,
Naturwissenschaften, Technik.
Ein herrlicher Bereich.
MINT-Menschen. Die Bock haben,
sich hands on zu engagieren
und aktiv zu werden,
damit hier im Netz
der MINT-Bereich
und alles damit verwandte
nicht so unnötig stereotypisch
bleibt.
Wenn ihr Lust habt, schreibt
eine E-Mail an info@funk.net
mit dem Betreff "MINT".
Und stellt euch vor, sagt uns,
was ihr gerne ändern würdet.
Schreibt mir
auch gerne in die Kommentare,
wie ihr das mit dem Gendern seht.
Ob ihr das auch so tricky findet,
wie ich.
Oder ob ich mir da
einen zu großen Kopf mache.
Danke, dass ihr diesem doch recht
untypischen Video zugehört habt.
Wir sehen uns näçhsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin: bleibt sicher.